what we were able to do best was pivot
quickly you know having such a small and
great team it allowed us to be a lot
more nimble so when we saw okay cool you
may not be able to get on the plane
that's fine we don't need to just do
luggage
let's be the go-to on the go brand
instead of just being in people's minds
travel it was really great
today's pets i have a frenchie i want
one let me okay
tell me blacker beige and we're sending
it out
on top of running not one but two
businesses jay is also stepping behind
the camera executive producing the new
fox drama the cleaning lady
i'm just a cleaning lady i can help you
make this disappear
as an executive producer and then of
course launching so many brands like is
there is there a couple of people that
you really look up to
honestly to begin with it was jessica
simpson i think seeing what she did with
starting her brand and all of that was
really inspiring and then followed
jess's album
you know now looking at producers bruce
witherspoon does incredible productions
and all of that so i feel like being
able to see them do it all
again allows me to feel like i can do it
too
[Music]